hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys i'm
salamander so today we're gonna check
out a video called batman and Shia
LeBouf versus Superman dawn of do it the
Shia LaBeouf is on Batman side guess so
I don't know we're seeing the video I'm
back inside - oh yeah man bang hands hot
suckers Badcock bet [ __ ] so he calls it
when he goes inside of a woman back hook
man is under surveillance I'm hope your
panic and confusion liquid crystals
oscillating rules are being broken
57million where's he gone ten that was
quite definitely almost into a state of
euphoria [ __ ] this is boring stop giving
up don't let you yesterday you said
tomorrow so just do it make your dreams
come true
just
nothing is in place
he's waiting for tell me to please yes
he can go away
that's some good editing that's some
really good editing you know like the
green screen was sometimes a little off
of course but the audio synching of
everything was smart and the placement
of him was really good that was what was
funny like him behind him just walked it
yeah oh and he was standing on the
Batmobile yeah there's some great stuff
that's especially rewarding because we
watched the actual trailer beforehand so
to see this like parody of it was really
good actual trailers like so intense I
like what they're doing all the Shia
LaBeouf stuff I do too I I think it was
like a genius move on Shia LaBeouf spark
you totally did over it like let me make
a motivational speech in front of a
green screen that way everyone can use
it like that's smart that's really smart
just wants to be viral ya know he has no
problem doing that he's like viral since
he was ten ever since he was a little
even-steven I love that show what a step
up for him to do this I know right going
crazy anyway guys thanks for saying that
was out I quite enjoyed that video if
you're new to the channel you can saying
that was out I quite enjoyed that video
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you could
check out salamander Sally's channel
salamander Sally's channel salamander
Sally's channel where actually there's a
video I just did with Sally that's on
our channel you should check it out and
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
and Twitter where if we get enough
followers we can get product placement
for things such as homosexual sunglasses
homosexual sunglasses are great
oftentimes you'll be suckin a man's dick
and they don't want to come on your face
but these sunglasses will prevent it
from getting into your eye
homosexual sunglasses
salamandra Sally's channels salamander
Sally sham camel Salomon channel
salamander Sally channels salamander
Sally shell salamander Sally's channel
salamander Sally channel channels
channel salamanders salamander Sally's
Channel Shh